we are continuing where we left off last
week
and we were discussing in general last
the things that invalidate a person's
fast
and we base this discussion
on the two
pillars of fasting that we learned the
week previous
we mentioned that fasting has two
pillars
he authored this book that we are
discovering and and taking our journey
through for the past
about a year
regarding the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he did not
write it in the way that
traditional books of fick are written
it's not categorized in that way
it doesn't
categorize things as the fukuha in their
exclusively written books on fil usually
categorize things
he just mentions what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam did and what
he did not do as we mentioned before
zadul ma'ad is a book which explains the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
it is not necessarily a book of fick
though it does contain filk it's not
necessarily a book of sira though it
does contain syrah et cetera and so it
is a very malleable malleable book that
has been written in a very unique
fashion
and so we being that ramadan is
in a few days
it's important that we review some of
the things that ibn is mentioned and
categorized them and some of the things
that he may not have mentioned in
which is what we're doing in order to
prepare ourselves
for
fasting the month of ramadan
so tonight inshaallah we're going to
discuss in detail the things that
invalidate a person's fast
and we're basing this on the two pillars
of fasting that we had learned
previously
we mentioned that fasting has two
pillars
the first pillar
is
having the intention to fast
prior
to the break of dawn of the day which
you wish to fast
though some scholars have
debated this
with regards to
fasting which is not obligatory
if a person's fast is not obligatory
they're fasting one day thursday they're
fasting the three days of the month
they're
just fasting
then they can have an intention
that doesn't start the night before
they can start their intention
as long as they haven't done anything
that day since the break of dawn that
would otherwise break their fast
but for obligatory fasting
a kaffara
fasting that is
the fast of ramadan
etc any fasting that is obligatory
binding
then a person must have his intention
prior to the break of dawn
and we mentioned the narration of hofsla
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
it
whoever has not
had the intention to fast prior to the
break of dawn then their fast is not is
not valid we mentioned the second pillar
of fasting
is refraining from anything that will
break your fast
and we discussed last week
that
those things that will break your fast
are six things
and everything else that will break your
fast
fall under the
generality of these six things
[Silence]
foreign
so there are things that may fall under
the generality of these six points that
we mentioned that break your fast these
six things that break your fast for
example
if an individual pleasures himself
or herself
to the point of climax this will
invalidate a person's fast
and this
falls under the generality of
of intercourse even though
the expiation of intercourse during the
day of ramadan is much more intense than
the expiation of
of this
and so we mentioned six things that will
break a person's fast
[Silence]
well
what is the first and second thing that
will break a person's fast
eating and drinking purposefully
what does that mean purposefully
that a person knows he's fasting
remembers at the time of eating or
drinking that he's fasting and still
eats or drinks something this will break
a person's fast
let's take an example about that
but first we will finish that
eating and drinking something
purposefully
or anything that goes the path of eating
or drinking so through the nose or
through the mouth
or anything that takes the place of
eating or drinking an iv for
instance
so there's three three things that fall
into the generality of eating or
drinking purposefully
what are the first two things that break
a person's fast we mentioned there are
six things that break a person's fast
we mentioned these generally last week
this week we're going to
dive into them and dissect them so that
we have
proper knowledge about these things that
will break a person's fast we said no
one and two
eating or drinking
purposefully we understand what
purposefully means
or anything that goes the path of these
two things eating or drinking
or anything that takes the place of
eating or drinking
this will break a person's fast
so let's take an example
let's look at an example of eating or
drinking something
that will
take the place
or eating or drinking something
purposefully
let's say a person is fasting
and they go into
a store
or something and they buy a bunch of
grapes
and so this person
is has bought these grapes and
he starts to eat these grapes one at a
time
as he's walking out as he's strolling
he's eating these grapes all the while
forgetting that he is fasting which is
actually a lot easier to do
in a place
where we live because
most people are not fasting around us
if you're in a muslim country where
everybody's fasting and you walk around
eating grapes you know you're liable to
get
you know bombarded with people reminding
you but if you live
where the majority of people around you
aren't fasting it's very easy to forget
so
he is eating these grapes
and then he gets to the last grape
and just as he goes to put this grape in
his mouth he remembers that he's fasting
and so
he says well it's i've eaten i've eaten
all these grapes
one isn't gonna hurt so he eats the last
grape which grape broke his fast
the last one
the last one is the one that broke as
fast correct
because the ones that proceeded the ones
that came before
he had not
remembered that he was fasting
and so
the whole bunch of grapes didn't break
as fast what broke is fast
one grape right
this is what we mean when we say
eating or drinking purposefully
right
the second thing that falls into this
generality is anything that goes the
path of eating or drinking
right
so for example people often ask this is
actually very recurring question
if a person is fasting they can fast but
they have some kind of pill that they
have to take at a certain time
does this break your fast what is the
answer
is
is a pill
food or drink
it's not food or drink right but does it
go the path of food and drink yes
so does it take the ruling of food and
drink
yes
so yes it would break your fast
whether you have to fast or not
or whether you're exempt of fasting
because of this medicine that you may
have to take at a certain time is an
issue
that
would need to specifically be referred
to
a person of knowledge because people
have different circumstances
so the point here is that something that
takes the path of eating and drinking
likewise
what takes the path of eating and
drinking
something that is
inhaled through the nose
this takes the path of
eating and drinking because the nose
goes directly into the into the throat
right
so for
example a
you know
yeah the thing that you use to
shoot liquid up into your nose
right and sniff it into your nose
well obviously when you do this you're
going to taste it you're going to feel
it going down your throat this this will
break a person's fast
one of the type one of the ways that
black seed is used the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam mentioned
that black seed is a cure for many
diseases
is in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam there are a few methods
that were
used to administer
black seed is a remedy and one of them
is through the nose
right
so they would
make it into a liquid form and it would
go into the nose
this will break a person's fast
likewise the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and where do we where do we get
the evidence for this
the prophet salallahu
he mentioned
teaching one of the companions
to
how to make wudu he said
is
[Silence]
in a narration teaching one of the
companions in a sunan
how to make
wudu he said
in the part regarding
taking the wubu into his nose he said
and
sniff deeply
or snort deeply into your nose the water
of
unless you are fasting
so what do we understand from that
do not
take the water deeply into your nose why
not
because taking the water deeply into
your nose while you are fasting
the water will or you know taking the
water deeply into your nose will result
in some of the water
going down the throat
right
and so the scholars mentioned that what
breaks a person's fast eating or
drinking purposefully
or anything that takes the path of
eating and drinking
this
brings up something such as an inhaler
a person that uses an inhaler
a mist or a
gas
that goes into a person's lungs
for the relief of asthmatic symptoms
will this break a person's fast the
correct opinion is that it will not
because
it is
in a gases state
and it goes into the lungs
and it does not take the place of eating
or drinking
and
if there is a tiny tiny tiny minuscule
amount
that may happen to go into the into the
stomach
it is
so tiny that it is
not considered to be
something which is mentionable
just when a person makes wudu
will there not be a tiny tiny tiny trace
of the water in their mouth
after they make udu
yeah right
and where will that water and eventually
go
into the throat right but that will not
breaker persons will do correct
now
the third thing is that which takes the
place of eating and drinking
and this gets us into many of the things
that a person will
do
during their day of fasting
such as visiting a doctor etc
a person may get a shot
a person may
have to go to the dentist and get a
novocaine shot a person may
have to get some kind of shot for
arthritis or a vaccine or or
you know vitamins or something this
will this break a person's fast
well let's go through it is it food or
drink
no
does it go the path of food or drink no
does it take the place of food or drink
no then it will not break a person's
fast
and it will not break a person's fast
what will break a person's fast is
something that takes the place of eating
or drinking such as
an iv that that is used to
replenish the bodies
the
replenish the body's hydration
right
person is
malnourished or dehydrated they go to
the hospital and they put an iv that
drips right this takes the place of
this takes the place of drinking water
or may take the place of eating
this
will break a person's fast
what about lotions
this won't break a person's fast right
what about patches a nicotine patch
for smokers
will this break a person's fast no
what about something that is put in the
eye administered through the eye
such as
eye drops or
you know
mascara for women or you know
for men or women whatever it is will
this break a person's fast
no what about
something that enters the mouth but is
then
spit out of the mouth without swallowing
any of it will this break a person's
fast
let's say a cook is cooking his job is
to cook and he has to taste the food
or taste what he's doing to see where
it's at but he then spits this out will
it break as fast
[Silence]
that tasting something will not break a
person's fast as long as they
spit it out right
right
also
what about something that enters the
body
but does not take the path of food or
drink
such as a suppository for instance
will this break a person's fast
no
this will not break a person's fast it's
not food or drink
it does not take the path of food or
drink it does not take the place of food
or drink
so we have
a narration
[Silence]
allah has forgiven and pardoned my
my followers
from anything
that is a result of
mistake forgetfulness or forced
right
or is done under duress compulsion
so these are three things
mistake
forgetting
or compulsion
these things
are pardoned and forgiven so anything
that happens under these three
circumstances does not break a person's
fast
so we have an example we have already
taken an example of
forgetfulness
what about a mistake
let's say a person is making wudu and
some of the water goes down into their
stomach will this break their will no
because it happened as a result of what
mistake
what about
a person brushing his teeth is that
permissible while you are fasting
[Silence]
m
an example of a mistake
is a person for for instance brushing
his teeth
while he's fasting is it permissible to
use toothpaste while you are fasting
yes
it's in the mouth and it's
it's then spit out right
but if a person is is is fasting and he
accidentally swallows some of the
toothpaste will it break as fast
no
likewise masturine
that which they are forced
compelled to do under duress
will this
break a person's fast no do you remember
the news stories a few years ago
about
some of our muslim brothers and
sisters in china that were being forced
by the government to break their fast
you remember those stories
did any of those people break their fast
no
so they're forced to eat right and so
they eat and they drink and all that are
they still fasting or not
yes
still fasting
you can't you can't force someone to
break their fast it's impossible
so that is the first and second thing
that will break a person's fast
[Silence]
so the first and second
is eating and drinking purposely
or that which takes the route takes the
path of eating and drinking
or that which takes the place of eating
and drinking so we understand that right
everybody clear on that any
questions or issues to rise with regards
to that
name
the person is swallowing it
yeah that will break your fast yeah
biting biting the nails swallowing the
nail clippings this will break a
person's fast
whether there is a kaffara or not for
this is a difference of opinion
you know there's other things that occur
that are
against a person's will
you're walking and a bug flies into
your mouth or
dust or
you know things this this will not
break a person as fast
steam will not break a person's fast
what if they go
and inhale the steam on purpose will
this break a person's fast yes
[Silence]
a
that's a good question
he asked with regards to a person who
has maybe some bleeding in their mouth
and they swallow this blood
if it happens by mistake it will not
break a person's fast if a person
intentionally continues to swallow his
blood coming out into his mouth this
will break a person's face
[Silence]
foreign
is
[Silence]
the third thing that will break a
person's fast is
inducing vomiting
making yourself vomit
and this is what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was mentioned specifically
[Silence]
whoever makes himself vomit
than he is to
make up
that day in fasting
and whoever
is overcome with the urge to vomit
unintentionally
then
this person does not have to make up
that day
so whoever is overcome with the urge to
vomit
a person smells something sees something
remember something feels sick that day
and they vomit then this person's fast
is intact but if a person makes himself
vomit
then this will
break a person's fast
[Silence]
m
the next fourth and fifth thing so we
mentioned
three things so far
right eating and drinking
purposely
or
that which
takes the path of eating or drinking or
that which takes the place of eating and
drinking the third is
that a person
induces vomiting a person
purposely vomits makes himself vomit
right
fourth and fifth
is
menstruation
or postpartum
we mentioned administration and
postpartum
they share all of the rulings in islamic
law except for three places and fasting
is not one of them so anytime you see
that
menstruation has
a ruling
then postpartum has that ruling as well
postpartum meaning after birth
so that blood that continues after birth
up to 40 days
that it takes the ruling of
of menstruation
so if a woman
is fasting
and then before meghrib she gets her
cycle does she have to make that day up
huh
none
she has to make that day up
okay i have a question
what about and this is important for the
men to know as well as the women
what about if a woman is
has her cycle and then it stops during
the day of ramadan
does she have to make up the rest of the
day fasting
make that day up
he has to make it up right now
i've been to the cartoon hat
come
[Silence]
foreign
the sixth thing and final thing is
intercourse
and following that is
what we've mentioned before
no need to mention it again
and we mentioned that
if a person forgets and they stop
immediately
will this break a person's fast no this
will not break a person's fast some of
the scholars said yes it will
but the correct opinion is that it will
not break a person's fast if they cease
immediately
when they remember or let's say when
they hear the event right this will not
break a person's face
[Silence]
m
foreign
[Silence]
i